do we need nuclear energy to stop
climate change
more and more voices from science
environmental activists
and the press have been saying so in
recent years
but this comes as a shock to those who
are fighting against nuclear energy
and the problems that come with it so
who's right
well it's complicated to slow rapid
climate change
the world needs to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions to net zero
in 2018 three quarters of global
emissions were released through energy
production
namely by burning fossil fuels energy
is a broad term that describes all sorts
of stuff from moving things and people
around
to putting things big and small together
or heating our homes
currently 84 percent of the world's
primary energy comes from fossil fuels
33 from oil 27 from coal
and 24 from gas around 10
of the global oil supply is just used to
burn in boilers to make our homes cozy
and warm
only about 16 of global energy is from
low emission sources
almost 7 from hydroelectric 5
from solar wind bio energy wave tidal
and geothermal combined
and about four percent from nuclear
so we pretty much rely on coal oil and
gas to keep our civilization going
which means it's actually very hard to
transition away from them
to have a chance of escaping fossil
fuels without throwing humanity back
into the stone age
one of the most impactful things we can
do is to electrify as many sectors as
possible electricity is the stuff that
appears
like magic when you plug something into
a socket so you can watch youtube
every industry that can switch from
burning fossil fuels to electricity
needs to do so
from electric cars to electric heaters
why do we need to bet so hard on
electricity
because we can produce electricity with
low emission technologies
like solar wind or nuclear so
electricity is a real lever for a
radical transition
but there are a few problems making this
transition
really hard first of all in most places
in the world
electricity is still generated mostly by
burning fossil fuels
and not only that in the last 20 years
the world's
electricity usage increased 73
in absolute terms while we are
installing renewables at record speeds
at the same time the amount of fossil
fuel we're burning for
electricity still keeps rising year by
year
renewables have so far not been able to
catch up with the demand for new
electricity
and so despite our progress emissions
from electricity are still
rising worldwide the other alternative
to
fossil fuels is nuclear and even though
it's not renewable
its greenhouse gas emissions are tiny
compared to burning stuff
but in the last 20 years nuclear has
basically stagnated
countries like china india and south
korea built new reactors
while germany and japan have been
actively taking their nuclear plants
offline which seems a bit weird if we
look at the countries with the most
low carbon electricity in the world that
get most of their juice mainly from two
sources
nuclear or hydropower take france and
sweden
in france only around 10 percent comes
from fossil fuels
while 67 comes from nuclear and 23
from renewables primarily hydro in
sweden almost
30 comes from nuclear power and about 45
from hydro so we know that nuclear
energy can work at scale
on the technical side because of the
lack of investment and innovation in the
last few decades
the majority of the world's nuclear
reactors are pretty old
technology that's very costly to replace
in most western countries building
nuclear reactors has become
very expensive for a variety of reasons
like a loss of know-how in constructing
them
policy changes and increased regulatory
constraints
so it can take a decade or longer just
to finish a power plant
in contrast countries like south korea
china india and russia
are able to build new nuclear reactors
comparatively quickly and at a
competitive cost
still generally in the west the current
generation of nuclear power plants are
more expensive
to build and maintain the most fossil
fuel alternatives
there are also the concerns about
nuclear waste and the fear of accidents
but we cover those in other videos in
more detail
we have designs for nuclear reactors
that solve many of their problems
namely small reactors that take less
time and money to get started
there are also next generation
technologies that can already turn
radioactive waste into new fuel
but so far these have not been deployed
at a scale where they can have a
significant impact on the nuclear sector
considering these uncertainties some
argue that nuclear power is a dangerous
relic of the past and that we should
just let it go
and focus on renewables but while
renewables undoubtedly are the future of
electricity they still have their own
huge challenges to overcome
before they can take over the vast
majority of the electricity grid
the main problem is reliability and
consistency
it's not always windy and the sun
doesn't always shine especially in the
mornings and evenings when humans need
the most electricity
the variations between seasons don't
make this issue easier
to make renewables reliable and not risk
blackouts
we need massive storage capacities where
we can save energy collected when the
sun or wind are at their peak
and release it later when we actually
need it
until this is possible other sources of
electricity need to provide a
controllable load
that creates the reliability of supply
that our civilization needs to run
properly
eventually we will be able to do this
with renewables
but we need a lot of batteries or
storage power plants
right now we simply don't have the tech
and the capacities to make this
transition
fast enough to replace fossil fuels but
even if we could
there's another aspect we have to take
into account
we're not just trying to kick fossil
fuels out of electricity
we're trying to replace energy with
electricity
if we're going to electrify sectors that
currently use fossil fuels
like cars or heating we will need
significantly more
electricity than we're currently using
everywhere
around the world and if the electricity
needs of the world population continue
to grow as they have over the last 20
years
we'll need even more it all comes down
to one thing
no energy source is perfect all have
their own unique problems
both renewables and nuclear energy
require time
investment and technological innovation
on their own
neither is ready to remove fossil fuels
from our electricity grid
although activists on both sides claim
that they are
in the end the question is how we want
to deal with all these challenges
should we give up nuclear immediately
and at least temporarily
accept higher emissions will we try to
extend
the life of current nuclear reactors and
shut them down
afterwards while solving the
shortcomings of renewables
or will we invest in new nuclear
technology to get
new nuclear reactor types that are
cheaper and safer
or will we maybe do both
opinion part starts here
considering the risks that climate
change poses for the biosphere and
humanity
any technology that has a chance of
contributing to a solution should be
pursued
that's just good risk management and
strategy
if preventing rapid climate change as
quickly as possible is our goal
it might be a good idea to see nuclear
and renewables not as opponents
but as partners we know there's no time
to waste
so we should keep all of our lower
mission players on the field
as things are both nuclear and
renewables need innovation and
investment
but if we don't know yet which
technology will be ready how quickly
why not just invest in both and see what
happens
and on the topic of current capacities
if we take nuclear energy offline right
now
then that missing capacity will be
replaced at least partially
by fossil fuels even if new nuclear
power plants in the west
are expensive in the long run it may be
cheaper to build them
as long as they prevent more fossil fuel
capacity being added
and paying for the consequences of rapid
climate change
so do we need nuclear energy
well it really depends how hard we
choose to make things for ourselves
and in a world that's already having a
really hard time quitting fossil fuels
why should we make things harder than
necessary
starting the change process and trying
something new
is always difficult luckily you don't
have to do it all on your own
if you want to get out of a rut we've
got something for you
we are big fans of skillshare an online
learning community that offers thousands
of classes for all skill levels
and tons of creative disciplines like
illustration animation or film and video
or you could try a class on home
decoration growing houseplants
or playing the guitar there's something
for everyone really
unlimited access to all the classes is
less than ten dollars a month with an
annual premium membership and the first
one thousand cutscout viewers to click
the link in the description will get a
free trial
since we started working with skillshare
you our viewers have taken over 100 000
hours of classes
including our own three skillshare
classes on how we make our animations
if you want to learn more about motion
graphics give them a try
and if you need an extra little push to
get you going
maybe get started with some advice on
motivation
and inspiration we liked the scientific
method for artists
find inspiration get motivated and grow
your creative skills by kendall hillegas
in this class kendall explains her
four-phase process for exploring and
figuring out your direction as an artist
for us it was a great way to get into
the flow of creating something
but anything that makes you feel excited
and sparks new ideas is a great first
step
if you want to get creative with new
skills and support kotskazak
give it a come go
[Music]